foreign
City and talk to Eric what's up Eric
hello hey man
hey John thanks for taking my call good
course again yeah man and so you called
in in back in 2021 about a divorce
you're thinking about a divorce tell me
about that
so golly that's a lie it's a recap
was my wife gave me a an unexpected uh
news it was on our 11th anniversary that
she had been working to get a divorce
and I didn't know it was coming
I hadn't we hadn't talked about it the
divorce or separation it was never at
least from my perspective on the table
and uh
I was pretty broken to say the least and
I called in looking for some for some
advice on how to first of all how to
cope and how to move forward and how to
work on some of my issues did I screw it
up yeah
no no it's anything I was a screw-up man
you you were your advice was uh uh uh it
was potent in a good way it it was some
advice that I needed to hear that I
didn't have anyone else to tell me what
to do namely
the thing I wasn't doing is I wasn't
talking to people I was isolating and
trying to be private about it and you
said dude get some friends in your world
yeah and so
I uh I took that advice the best I could
and furthermore
decided to make myself better rather
than blaming the situation and that's
what I'm working on for a couple years I
love it dude so how can I help you today
man
so without uh attempting not to get into
too much detail
I you know the one very bad piece of
advice I was given at the time was don't
talk to anyone this is from her and her
side of things this is between you and
me don't talk to anyone about it just
you know maybe your parents or something
but don't talk to anyone this is between
you and me and I took that advice oh no
did you I I did well that was before
that was before I spoke with you and oh
did I have the same did I have the exact
same responses I just did
basically yes oh gosh you don't you
don't get to throw grenades at my house
and then expect me to cover for why
their houses and Ashes like if you blow
my house up you can blow it up I'm gonna
tell everybody all right you don't get
to tell me that geez and I wish I I wish
I would I had done that you know what
you're saying at the time I was I was
desperate to save my marriage I was
already in the process before I got the
news that of working on myself and being
a better husband and and uh I was It was
kind of you know one of those three
steps forward four steps back two steps
forward one step back you know one of
those that I was making progress and so
I was surprised to get the news anyway
the so I I tried to comply in order to
I'm in my head I was the story I was
telling myself was
if I show her I'm being kind and
compliant then she'll see that maybe I
am more workable and than she thinks and
maybe she'll come around
and uh and that's Eric thinking that
this divorce ever had anything to do
with him in the first place
yes and that's been part of my journey
over the past couple years is realizing
this has a lot less to do with me than I
was led to believe Eric she bailed on
you because something was going on with
her
yeah you don't you don't drop a bomb on
an 11th anniversary with no
conversations no lead up no discussion
unless something's going wrong sideways
inside of you
I'm sure that in retrospect you you've
I'm sure you could have done things
differently let's make no mistake but
absolutely brosh
yeah that's not on you it would be
unfair of me to say
it was all her you know I had I had my
own issues they weren't nearly to the
extreme that she has since led me to
believe but there there were some
problems uh many of which your last call
I was talking about honesty I had some
honesty issues sure that I had to work
on and I've gotten a lot better at over
the years and so awesome tell him man it
does it does get better but you also
heard my question right
um what's your body trying to protect
you from and sometimes people develop
dishonesty because they grow up in such
toxic sick situations that their body
knows if you tell the truth here it's
simply not worth getting hit over over
and over and over and so let's create a
neutral path it's like a like one of
those walkways in a in an airport like
it's just like a moving sidewalk I'm
just gonna create that so that I can
have a frictionless life right it's not
it's still dishonesty it's still a lie
it's still not true
um but man sometimes people come by
their dishonesty honestly right
yeah but so where are you right now yeah
so so to Circle back to your question is
I have I I took much of your advice and
put my shoulder to the wheel and I've
been working on me for well since 2021
and I have come along with therapy
uh built you know rebuilding some
relationships with family and uh
essentially making myself be the guy
that I want to be and it was a hard it
was and it is a hard Road it continues
to be a hard Road right but I like the
Eric today
infinitely more than I liked the Eric
back then dude that's awesome man good
thing it's it's it's you know in your
call was instrumental so thank you now
you asked what is my question so despite
all of my growth despite all of the
progress I've made
during that divorce process because I
did keep to myself
what I didn't know is that she was not
of course
and she had been going to anyone in our
universe who would listen including my
dear friends and family members
with wild accusations that I never heard
in the courtroom you know such as he was
abusive he was
controlling he didn't let me spend money
he didn't let me visit my family the
things that were wildly untrue
and uh unfortunately I don't know what
to attribute to social climate or what
have you but a lot of people vast bulk
of people
at best decided to cut ties with me Eric
I'm gonna tell you something really hard
I'm going to interrupt and tell you
something really hard yep thank God
they're gone
here's why
if one of my if my wife called any
number of my buddies this isn't just
limited to my core crew any number of my
friends is she called any number of her
friends
and said John is abusive
he won't let me fill in the blank
the number of them that their first
instinct would be like no way
followed by I'm calling him
or I'm going I'm showing up at his house
it would be a flood
because I've got that level of trust and
rapport with him they know me I'm an
open book I'm just I'm as wide open as
could be now if she called her friends
it's like John's always late to
everything and he's a goofball and his
music is terrible yeah they believe that
no question about that right but here's
the deal the fact that those people in
your orbit
never came to you with that never
challenged you on that never met you in
your front yard and said who Do You
Think You Are
and gave you an opportunity to explain
you don't want those people in your life
because they were never a part of your
life to begin with
they were leeches they were hanger ons
they were along for the ride or for the
party dude but they weren't in it with
you
and I know it's it's hard when you think
I had it's like having a hundred
thousand followers on Instagram and
suddenly they cancel all the Bots and
you're down to twenty thousand
and it hurts because you lost 80 000
followers but you they weren't real to
begin with
that's what just happened with you and
you can look at the landscape and the
number and see how it just it it went
zooped and dwindled down but man I'm
telling you right now you're in a better
place to rebuild something new forget
those folks and you you've listened to
show long enough I don't normally say
that I have little little patience at
all
for friends who don't have the courage
to say let me talk to him
I I
invested enough that I'm involved in
this because we're we're we're close
we're connected we're friends we're
family I'm calling them if you don't if
I'm not worth a phone call then so be it
and you know it's I'm grateful you said
that I I'm coming around to to finally
believing that my folks gave me similar
advice and
I think
uh to wrap up the background and to get
to the actual question I suppose is
I think it made it really hard for me
not to believe the accusations because I
thought we were ride or die I was a guy
who showed up when we're moving I was
the first guy to show up I was the guy
who showed up when you're hurting
I was I was the one who as you say I did
show up on the yard
I did call them
and so when everyone else seemed to bail
you know it devastated me so this is the
actual question it was
despite my growth I have this I didn't
used to be this way but I have this
really uncomfortable uh
defense mechanism in my body I guess
let's make it difficult for me to
I thought I was doing everything right
as a friend
why is it that you know I guess what I'm
saying what am I trying how do I
articulate that I'll answer it because I
know you're trying to say you got to go
again
yeah it's kind of like talking to
somebody and they're like hey I've got
this much money to buy a house but I
live in California and houses are
tripled the the price as they are at
Canton Kansas so is it cool if I just go
ahead and buy this
and I would tell them
like math doesn't get a pass in
California
and so I would tell you
your wife burned the landscape clean
and you got to see what trees in the
field remained and there was many fewer
trees than you thought
and that doesn't give you a pass on all
the loneliness research that exists that
says if you don't have a group of people
you can be yourself with be vulnerable
with you will die
and I'm feeling that you know it's been
nearly two years now and it's been I
still feel pretty lonely there are some
new people in my world that are
get into that friendship point but it's
definitely a loneliness haven't felt in
a long time so I guess the are there any
tools
that I can develop or get
to help myself open up again and be
myself with people uh to to open myself
up to be vulnerable
the only ones that I've seen be
effective at all and the science on this
is is dismal and again it's hard right
it'd be really hard to do a like a
controlled study on this but
the two things I've seen be successful
is find shared experiences and go first
what I mean by that is join a soccer
team or a softball team or a
chess club join an existing thing where
you all can do a thing together where
you're not just sitting at dinner
staring at each other and being like so
how do you feel because that's awkward
and weird but go to the fights go to the
fights go to the fights and eventually
like has happened
um I watched the UFC fights with a group
of guys and we every time there's a big
fights we all get together at one guy's
house and we watch them and after two
three four five times somebody texted me
and said hey when you go to lunch
and then things got real but we had
shared experiences we were cheering we
were laughing we were ragging and making
fun of each other having a good old time
and then there was some safety built so
that someone could say hey I needed a
question about my kid
or
um the second one is just go first and
be weird you be the house that every
time there's UFC have people over or
whatever sporting event or whatever
Bible study or whatever thing is like
hey I I just went and bought five
thousand dollars worth of Rogue uh
lifting equipment I've got to work out
at my house every morning at six o'clock
you guys are all welcome maybe one guy
shows up maybe no guys show up but maybe
if you guys will show up and then one or
two of them will continue to show up and
then y'all will go grab coffee together
we all go hunting together you go
fishing together you go I I don't know
go knit sweaters together I don't care
what you do but
um
it's easy to get into this
circling the airport in the plane where
you're waiting for somebody to invite
you and nobody invites you and that that
reinforces the message that everyone
sucks and that nobody wants to be around
you or you go and it's a little bit
awkward and a little bit weird and that
just reinforces that every you see what
I'm saying it just kind of it's
self-perpetuating so the only way
through it is through it you have to
head into the Storm Into the Storm Into
the Storm over and over and over again
and your body is doing exactly what it's
designed to do which is to keep you from
getting hurt again
and I wish there was any other way
around it you just can't get a pass on
math right it just is it just I mean
just I mean this is this is the brutal
part of getting having somebody break
your heart
mm-hmm
yeah it's like getting bit by a
rattlesnake and yet the only way to live
is by handling rattlesnakes right you
got to go back out there again and risk
it again
well I've done hard for a couple years I
can keep doing hard for a little while
longer I think
can I can I be super honest with you I
think you've done
peripheral hard
which you have to do right you got to
keep the lights on and the bills paid
you got to keep food in your stomach
right I think you're about to enter into
the season of super hard the beauty of
super hard is I have found it's if you
will head directly into it it's not as
as long as people think it is
but it is painful
that might be taking six or seven of
those folks that actually just
completely bailed on you call them back
take him for coffee
and say hey what stories were told about
me
why didn't you call
like was that not worth a phone call
and there might be some closure there
and people may say hey I'm really sorry
because also two years ago was a
millikov and everybody was crazy
everybody was scared everybody was
everything
and so it may be worth you circling back
and letting people have the opportunity
to say I'm so sorry I screwed this up so
bad
and you can rebuild something there
maybe
sure that seems logical to me but I
would pick five or six of them that you
love and if you don't reach out to them
write them a letter that you're never
going to send
and just let him like get that out of
your body onto a piece of paper
I thought I was at least worth a phone
call I thought I was at least worth a
confrontation at my front door
if you thought I was really abusing my
wife I was really controlling her and
wouldn't let her call out the phone
would let her visit people
that's crazy behavior was that not worth
that a phone call
and quite awesome Eric they may say well
you did this and this and this and so it
was a logical and you may find out man
I've really had a lot of growing because
I kind of put this image out there who
knows what you'll learn
But ultimately
hardest part about broken relationships
is that our body puts a GPS pin in there
and says never again
those relationships got us hurt last
time we're not doing this this time
and the only way to health and healing
and being well is with other people so
you got to go again and you got to go
again
head on the line Eric I'm gonna send you
all of the questions for humans cards
for friends
um Jen like I don't know guys night
girls night friends couples and I'm
gonna send you a copy of own your past
change your future too
um
check it out it's got a whole section in
there about making friends
um give that a read and then dude call
me back anytime I'm really really proud
of the work you're doing it's amazing